it's exclusive we're not talking to
anyone else we really like each other
we just don't want to put a label on it
yet alright so that clip we just played
with you
chase avoiding relationship questions
that was a few weeks ago you're not
putting a label on it and now that
you're on the et set it's my job to
figure out if we're still not putting a
label on it where are we at
alright I'm taking it as slow as humanly
possible okay before I pop the question
okay but we are very exclusive invariant
to each other okay I like that so pop
what question pop the girlfriend
question oh is that a question you have
to pop yeah I usually think you wait for
the engagement okay the girlfriends okay
oh I don't want you thrown that you're
popping the question question okay so
you you're not sure but you're it's
coming yeah all right so it seems like
you guys are this very United family you
sat down here and before we started the
show you have a whole language that
you're talking to each other so what
does it take to get in the house and
what is it like living with all your
friends you want to take it Mary no
honestly it took me hanging out with
them and getting to know everybody and
as soon as I got comfort with her and
then I got close with him and that close
with her yeah are you guys enemies no I
actually mix really nice to me okay
everyone's really nice to me but as soon
as I got close with that Thomas popped
the question if I want it to be in the
high palace and you guys are popping
questions so what does it take to get in
the house what are you always lure to
invite someone in for us we are looking
for the right fit it doesn't take
honestly for us we just want anyone that
fits with everybody if we all get along
and we think they are a good fit for
everybody and like connect with us as a
whole then that's when we decide over
like the course of takes like a month or
a month and a half yeah you were hanging
out with Larry before you joined yeah I
feel like there's no like criteria okay
besides like being a hard worker and
like someone
willing to you know like work and get
where we all are and like I guess like
stay motivated throughout it all and
like not get distracted yeah it is kind
of hard you know like living with
everybody it is hard to like be serious
at points but like I think it's business
yeah if you can come together and like
you know get to work then yes and I feel
like you're the gatekeeper yeah so
you're you decide who's in you decide
who's out have you had to kick anyone
out yet yeah but today's a new day here
a little bit of a gatekeeper yeah yeah
I've keep like the manager role kind of
in the house keep everyone on track one
of the cool things about larae that it's
that he like has a really really bubbly
personality especially online like with
his YouTube channel he does not just a
tick talker yeah that's a lot of value
in a lot of different ways especially
his editing capabilities are amazing his
videos are amazing it's tic TOCs are
amazing like but it's a different style
than a lot of people we already have in
the house that was something we're
looking for it's like oh we have X
amount of dancers at X amount of boys
that are good-looking we need weight
like we need to go and we need someone
who's talented in a different way as
well hype house is right here on the et
stage now say something nice about me
just kidding so I thought it was really
cool that you guys collaborated with
this girl who invented the renegade and
then kind of didn't get the credit for
it tell me about this situation okay so
um we actually met her at the yeah we
met her at the NBA all-star weekend and
it was like really cool I think it was
really fun to like finally meet someone
that's like behind literally the most
viral dance on tik-tok and um I mean I
think the entire situation was kind of
like a miscommunication in a way like I
didn't really know initially who made
the dance really hard to like find the
root of creators especially on tech talk
whenever there's like new trends and
like things popping up but um it was
really cool to like finally put a face
to the her name and like get to meet her
and like do the dance with her I thought
it was really cool of you to take a 14
year old and help her build her clout
she did create that and then for you
guys to take her sword on your wing and
be like hey like yeah we we're the
biggest that exists and we're gonna help
get a little bit uh that's claw yeah I
would have nice wheat I think it was
like a lot of it had to do with like um
I guess you could say like people not
understanding that we truly didn't know
you know we really didn't know it was
never intentional and like trying to
take everyone else's dance and like I
mean I had only done renegade about like
like three times on my page initially
it's like I really had no idea I'd like
to sing on before you page like you see
so many videos that you never know who
created a certain thing so like getting
to see who does create it is like super
cool because you're like okay Wow like
this dance is viral and like everyone
knows this dance so yes everyone but me
so I am here to learn the dances today
Addison you're you're gonna teach me if
this is so embarrassing for me and I'm
so old
Addison you're teaching me some hip
moves okay come on stand out
all right now I just want to let
everyone know a former professional
dancer right here so I've got moves I've
got high kicks
I feel like tick tock I was made for it
okay I'm not cool enough and so Addison
is gonna help me be cool right now all
right teach me teach other moves girl oh
you look like you are um it's not really
called anything what would I call it the
body roll the body by air oh yeah oh
you're right we could definitely do say
that okay so like we'll just add a
little more movement before so yeah arm
arm arm arm then straight down straight
down they down up and then we're going
to go right okay now Batman next dance
man it's so good you're a natural
helicopter hands is teaching me this
Avani
wanna PS I love your style you're so
cute Cummings way come in here okay so
we're I did helicopter hands could look
at these nails beautiful okay helicopter
hands okay warm up my wrist okay okay
where did this come from I have no clue
it's like it was on musically before it
takes out okay so it's yeah it's really
over there here we go like how I feel
right now okay okay so you start like
this
yeah and then you cross
the top to bottom you turn your palms
facing each other huh
and then you wearing a ring that says
golf yeah okay here we go five in this
is intense
okay yeah so it's like out and in and
out yeah yeah almost hey hold on one
more time you decide keep your real
touch yeah at all times keep your wrist
yeah you're like trying to show her and
you're like okay here we go
okay five six helicopter hands what what
honestly this is my worst one but I need
something to work on I can't be perfect
at everything okay well thank you for
that not as good as this one
miss the hips I had Hey okay next now if
I want to throw it back all right
is this your signature style we call
help for this one she's really good at
okay with me ready to warm up stretch
okay perfect so I'd really like a
cricket
now cricket and all the crickets are bit
like this yeah yeah okay come on
just show me it okay fill out and I can
copy okay this wagon you gotta learn
yeah perfect
real Italy snap that's like I'm moving
like something ugh right there that's
for you page right there just this
that's it and then what do you do but I
heard that you already know how to do it
what is it show me yeah Larry Larry
Larry five six seven they throw back Wow
five six seven eight oh
okay wait I need everyone to do this one
[Applause]
I'm so proud of are you 12
five six seven eight I'm feeling really
good all right thank you guys so much
for the tutorial all of you this was
amazing a national big deal because et
is launching our tik-tok today which
means I'm about to body roll and
helicopter hands with all the
celebrities in Hollywood every time I'm
on the red carpet I'm so excited so
thank you for your help I'm coming for
you Nana Nana Nana toe up snap town
upset don't know right left okay over
time five six seven eight
you're gonna write yeah been fast fat
okay
Ichi theme and go up yes
what what Circle Circle front side throw
the wall okay
[Music]